we're talking a lot about coronavirus
today not because we are in a crisis
pandemic in the United States right now
but because Donald Trump's
administration is so unprepared and so
incoherent that in the event that we
have an actual pandemic situation in the
United States we are potentially in
really big trouble and the cherry on top
of this atrocity is that Donald Trump
has put his vice-president Mike Pence in
charge of coronavirus and I really need
everybody to understand how ridiculous
and and just terrorizing this is Donald
Trump has cut funding to the CDC
Donald Trump is underfunding medical
research Donald from fired his pandemic
response team which we'll get to I could
give you this long list but then on top
of it he puts Mike Pence in charge of
coronavirus Mike Pence's plan to deal
with HIV as governor of Indiana was he
needed time to go home and pray on what
he was being asked to do pence enabled
the spread of HIV in Scott County
Indiana five years ago which led to more
than 200 people getting infected people
came to pence and said we need a needle
exchange program we need it now we can
put it in place right away can we do it
governor and Trump said I'm sorry pence
said I want to go home and pray on that
and he eventually signed the needle
exchange into action but said I will
tell you I do not support needle
exchange as drug policy as anti-drug
policy but but this is a public health
emergency so if it's an emergency you're
doing it because you agree it'll help
but you actually don't support it I mean
completely incoherent the guy barely
believes in science this is one of the
last people that should be dealing with
coronavirus and he is the person who
will be in charge never mind involved
this is actually serious people will die
check out Donald Trump announcing this
yesterday talking about how Mike Pence
he he said Pence is great on health care
he's very expert at the field what is he
talking about
I wish this were a joke I really do
because we're screwed with these people
in charge
of coz we're doing something else that's
important to me cuz he's been terrific
in many ways but he's also very good on
health care and we really followed him
very closely a lot of states too when
Mike was Governor Mike Pence of Indiana
they've established great health care
they have a great system they're a
system that a lot of a lot of the other
states have really looked to and changed
their systems they wanted to base it on
the Indiana system is very good very
good on health care states were
following Mike Pence's lead when he was
governor in Indiana could that possibly
be true I tried to find evidence of
states basing their health care
decisions on what Mike Pence did in
Indiana I couldn't find any evidence of
that if anybody can find evidence that
Mike Pence was leading the way on health
care as governor of Indiana please let
me know here's another clip and what
I've done is I'm going to be announcing
exactly right now that I'm going to be
putting our vice-president Mike Pence in
charge and Mike will be working with the
professionals and doctors and everybody
else that's working the team is is
brilliant I spent a lot of time with the
team over the last couple of weeks but
they're totally brilliant and we're
doing really well and Mike is going to
be in charge and Mike will report back
to me but he's got a certain talent for
this and I'm going to ask Mike Pence to
say a few words please thank you a
certain talent for this we are just in
such trouble here and medical experts
have responded to this totally bizarre
press conference yesterday saying what
Donald Trump is telling us is incoherent
Trump is incoherent about what he says
is going on and here is Trump again
insisting were totally prepared despite
having no evidence whatsoever that we
are prepared while telling I guess some
kind of jokes with Donald Trump doing
stay clean you don't have to necessarily
grab every handrail unless you have to
you know you do certain things that you
do when you have the flu I mean view
this the same as the flu when somebody
sneezes I mean
I try and bail out as much as possible
with the sneezing I had a man come up to
me a week ago I hadn't seen him in a
long time and I said how you doing he
said fine honey he hugs me I said are
you well he says no he said I have the
worst fever in the worst flu and he's
hugging and kissing me
so I said excuse me I went to southern
watching man so you have to do that you
know this is I really think doctor you
want to treat this like you treat the
flu right whatever happens we're totally
prepared we have the best people in the
world now okay I have to I've said from
day one I said when Trump says something
I agree with I will tell you I also bail
out when people start coughing and
sneezing I actually do something at
airports that my girlfriend finds very
embarrassing which is you know those
long hallways often at the airport where
you're either walking down there's gates
on the left and right and you're getting
to your gate or sometimes to get under
the tarmac you go on these really long
hallways to get from one section of the
terminal to the other I'll be wheeling
my my roller board bag someone will just
cough right into the air a foot away
from me I will just immediately beeline
away from them and a chart of course
parallel to the one where I was it's
totally obvious why I'm doing it it's BS
it's because of the person coughing
without covering their mouth my
girlfriend gets very embarrassed but I
bail out as well I was at a cafe over
the weekend working on some show stuff I
sit down with my cappuccino and my bagel
and the guy next to me it was sort of
like a bar set up with high stools where
you sit guy next to me starts a wet
cough right into the air I just grabbed
my stuff and moved he gave me a look
like I was being made know mean you were
the problem sir you were coughing into
the air so I agree with Trump there he's
completely right about bailing out when
people are coughing like that
but back to Mike Pence running this
thing I have a hard time imagining a
worse person to run coronavirus for the
United States and that's often the
outcome with Donald Trump what is the
worst possible solution to this issue
that's the one that Donald Trump picks
Mike Pence rejects the scientific
consensus on multiple issues how the
hell did you put
Mike Pence in charge of this and the
this is the risk he disagrees with the
intelligence experts on intelligence he
believes he knows more than his generals
about the military he disagrees with
medical experts about how prepared we
are on coronavirus it's tragic and I
said it before and I tweeted about it
and I'll say it again when people say
I'm not into politics it's just you know
I'm into other stuff very quickly we are
going to realize here
tragically how much politics is life and
death if you didn't know it already and
I hope that most of the people in the
audience already didn't know that we are
very quickly going to realize how life
and death
politics is it's tragic do you feel like
you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that there are just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about 8 bucks a month
but you can try it for free for a week
and get 25% off a subscription when you
go to blankest comm slash Pakman what
blink is does is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work I just finished listening to
catch and kill by Ronan Farrow super
interesting book probably already
familiar to some in my audience and a
really interesting take at how Harvey
Weinstein and his alleged transgressions
were brought to light excellent
investigative piece Blinky's has totally
transformed how I consume information I
love it of course I read a book in its
entirety when I can but there are simply
just so many books that I want to read
and would not have the time for if it
weren't for bling cast they have books
on politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 2020
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you